they give this as kind of an assumption
actually the textbook says
i'm elogy but we've talked about that
already it's uh busy
okay now before we move off that
why is this true or how can you show
that it's true it's sort of
an awkward way of writing things it's
like why not why
why have e and then put a log up there
in the power when you can just say
hey well as you'll see shortly it's sort
of more useful for calculus purposes
to have things with base a so that you
can prove things that you wouldn't
otherwise be able to do so
so how do we how do we show that this is
actually the case you might want to have
this off of the side
okay so let's just define for instance
let's let k equal to now
we're going to try and think about logs
and exponentials as inverse of each
other right so let's just start with
something simple
like that so that's natural log okay now
as you've been doing already can we
convert this
from a log equation to an exponential
equation how would i rewrite it
so it had no log expressions in it
okay base here becomes the base here
right
the subject is the power and that's what
you've got
okay all right but
hold on a second we're really really
close to here right
can you see i know what k is i've just
defined it
right so if i wanted to if it was
convenient for me i could just let's
let's bring this over here i can write e
to the power of instead of k
i'll just say natural log of a that's it
that's all there is to it okay
but people often get confused by this
they find it hard to remember okay but
it's a really really useful trick
so it's sort of it doesn't really fit
under
log laws or index laws it's kind of both
so you may like to put it under where
you've got your heading for log laws
because that's i suppose
that's the closest place you'll notice
where it would belong
right now since we've established that
they want us to use that to find the
derivative of
2 to the x which you actually already
know but they want you to use
this fact to put this in a form which
will actually put it okay
so how do we go about doing it what
would be the first step how could you
use
something like this somebody's done it
there's quite a few of you
someone suggest what's the first step
okay so so what i'm gonna try and use is
this two
right that's that's the problem as it
were okay so i'm going to replace that
that two with a e to the
log 2. okay so this is going to be the
derivative of
e to the log 2
to the power of x nothing in the
brackets that's my 2
okay so the whole thing is the power of
x
great now what think about your index
laws what can i do here that might make
things a little easier
for me my uh
my two my two powers here right they're
really
they're multiplying right and
multiplication can be done in any order
okay so i can swap the x and the log 2.
right so i can do this
let's see e to the x to the power of 2.
now why is this better than what i had
before
this this is something we talked about
this before i think i heard movements of
it
this is a problem i know more about than
this problem okay i can deal with this a
little better
because e to the x is something we're
super familiar with i could
differentiate this
with chain rule right there's my inside
function
what's the outside function what is the
answer
if you had to classify it you know all
kinds of families and functions right
how would you classify the outside thing
if you said let u equal to evx
what's the outside function
what kind of what kind of function is it
it's just a um isn't it isn't it the
first one that you learn
it's just a power function isn't it
because log 2 is just a constant it's a
weird constant
but it's just the constant okay so we
know that if you're differentiating x to
the power of n
then the derivative is nx to the
n minus 1. so in this case right what
you've got is
for n you've got log two that's
convenient
log two okay so what do you get there
well the power comes out the front the
power happens to be
log two and then you take one away from
the power
log two minus one
uh one okay happy yes
so let's bring that back down here
actually kind of skip the step we were
doing chain rule weren't we
okay so the whole thing about chain rule
is that you're gonna do the inside
then you're gonna do the outside
actually doesn't matter which one you're
doing okay
the derivative of the inside function is
e to the x
and then you multiply by the derivative
of the outside function which we just
worked out
okay so what have i got here now this is
log 2 but here i was doing
x to the power of log 2. this is e d x
okay
so log two's out the front times
e to the x and now i reduce the power by
one
log two minus one
how your brain is going so far are we
happy are there any problems
looks okay to me what might be the next
step
what can we do to make this a little
simpler
i can i can do some factorizing what
might be the most useful thing to
factorize out
okay so let's have a look at that for a
second e to the x um
you sort of know in advance that the e
to the x is going to go somewhere
because you know what this derivative is
you know what it's actually equal to and
it has no e to the x's in it
okay so when you have a look at what edx
terms you have you've got
this one and then you've got now okay
look at it carefully this guy here okay
it's a bit tricky because the power's a
bit weird can we rewrite it in a way
that would make it a little more obvious
what this is actually equal to and how
it interacts with this okay
when you've got say a to the power of m
minus n what's that equal to index
we're dividing are we okay because n to
the minus n
that's division okay so i have the same
thing here see i've got e to the x
there's a constant and that minus 1
means i'm going to be
dividing okay so let's keep rewriting
this i've got
e to the x i've got a log 2. now what do
i have here
e to the x times log two but then this
minus one
is going to be division okay do you see
that
okay so that's good that's nice
this guy this guy gold okay we're almost
there
aren't we uh it's kind of a bit cheating
since we already know what the answer is
going to be
so you're like good you got the log to
check okay
what do i do here how do i make it
clearest don't skip any steps
i'm going to do the same trick that i
did here
right but in reverse so to show that
this
there's a there's a 2 here there's a 2
hiding in there i want to switch these
back around so i've got the log 2 at the
front
let's swap those indices so e to the log
2 there and then the x is outside
aha see it there it is that's what we
started with
okay that's log 2 times
2 to the x as required okay
so the important thing for me is to make
sure that
probably the easiest uh steps to ski it
are things like when you swap these
powers around you're kind of like yeah
that's fine i don't know how to do that
okay
if it's a show question which is very
likely because
this is a really easy result to get you
can just quote it right if it's a show
question you're expected to show those
kinds of steps
right that kind of level of detail so
you're like yeah i know what's going on
i understand how to manipulate these
index laws to get the answer at the end
not just because i know what the answer
is already okay